remettre les états unis au centre de la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
c'était l'un des enjeux de cette
première journée du sommet virtuel sur
le climat joe biden a invité plus de
quarante dirigeants mondiaux à
s'exprimer sur cette thématique qui fait
l'objet d'un rare consensus à l'échelle
internationale deuxième à s'exprimer
après sa vice-présidente kamala harris
le locataire de la maison blanche a tenu
à montrer la détermination de washington
en la matière les etats unis s'engagent
à réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre de moitié d'ici la fin de cette
décennie
c'est ce que nous nous sommes fixés en
tant que nation
c'est ce que nous pouvons atteindre si
nous construisons une économie non
seulement prospère mais aussi plus
saines juste et propre pour le bien de
la planète
ces avancées vont permettre à l'amérique
d'arriver à une économie avec zéro
émission de co2 d'ici 2050 près de
quatre ans après l annonce par donald
trump du retrait américain de l'accord
de paris joe biden semble vouloir faire
du défi climatique un thème majeur de
son mandat une volonté d'accélérer la
lutte environnementale partagé par
emmanuel macron un seul objectif dans
les prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
accélérer accélérer sur la mise en
oeuvre des engagements à l'horizon 2030
qui soit précis mesurables vérifiables
au fond 2030 et le nouveau 2050
c'est ce plan que l'union européenne a
mis sur la table en décembre traduite
dans une loi climat européenne avec le
green deal pour lui donner corps dans un
climat géopolitique tendu l'enjeu
climatique semble réchauffer les
relations entre occident tout chinois et
russes le président chiche hunting qui
participait pour la première fois un
sommet international avec joe biden et
le président russe vladimir poutine ont
également tenu à démontrer leur
engagement en la matière fiscale à la
fédération de russie souhaite
sincèrement intensifier la coopération
internationale afin de poursuivre la
recherche de solutions efficaces aux
problèmes du changement climatique comme
d'ailleurs à tous les autres problèmes
mondiaux aiguë
nous continuerons à donner la priorité à
la préservation de l'environnement réel
suivre une voie de développement verte
et à faible émission de carbone
la chine s'efforcera d'atteindre le pic
des émissions de dioxyde de carbone
d'ici 2030 et de parvenir à la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2060 une
concorde internationale qui pourrait
pourtant avoir du mal à se conclure
autrement que par de simples
déclarations d'intention un motif
d'inquiétude pour la communauté
scientifique qui tient la sonnette
d'alarmé et réclament des engagements
plus contraignant pour les états l'onu
estime que la température pourrait
augmenter de 3 à 5 degrés d'ici la fin
du 21e siècle
bien loin de l'objectif de 1,5 degré
prônée par l'accord de paris